foreign
Erickson with my friend Aaron hello oh
that's such a quick nice hello look at
us wearing scary t-shirts look at those
words ghost spooky stuff ghosts we're
screaming we're gonna watch Saw Three
three
I hope they cut up more people what do
you think it's gonna be I think they're
gonna cut up a lot of people and make us
uh really yeah I think it's gonna be a
lot of torture points
okay that's what he thinks you guys need
to remember to leave a like type in the
computer and you ought to leave a
comment and be nice and cool and kind
and all you have to ring the bell
and don't forget we call you super sexy
if you join on patreon patreon.com and
then you get to watch me and Aaron watch
the entire movie a full reaction and
watch along sync up with your own
copying we can't show you the whole
movie like you sit there at home with
your popcorn with your candy you watch
with us the whole thing one happy family
all synced up watching saw three that
way you're not like I have to watch all
three alone you don't you watch it with
ah and also don't forget John and Greg
cover exclusive shows over there with
reactions and watch alongs and they've
got a lot of stuff it's like real
exclusive over there if you get on the
patreon so you got it you gotta you
gotta know what's up so get over there
get on it get on it are you ready for
start three oh my God Wrath I'm so ready
okay let's get into it
game over
oh my God all right immediately what
wait this is picking up for the last one
oh it is
okay all right come on you can get out
of this Steve Wahlberg I believe in you
yeah come on
yes use the shoe use other objects to
get things across the room we've learned
from the last movie we like this we love
this move anything on your body is a
tool
it was empty it was empty empty clip
to the light it's to the flashlight wow
that was kind of dumb
oh no dude okay
this is interesting because this one is
a direct continuation of saw two what I
felt like the first one was was not this
yeah yeah the second one I'm also like
that girl's not in the bathtub anymore
though or around right the new well yeah
because she came and closed the door on
him
that's not gonna work but they tried
that in 1987 he did not cut through his
cord he Baroque uh didn't he break it I
think he broke it he broke the saw last
night right yeah
oh it's the [__] oh I hated him
oh my God that's an old foot is that
from number one yeah oh that's number
one foot uh-uh that's Mr barky's foot
yeah we got a number one foot number two
body it's rough in here it's rough in
these streets in this room
okay I mean the other guy I feel like he
bled out I think so I think he bled out
bro come on
okay I wasn't ready I wasn't ready
I mean she left him alive she could have
killed him so like just call out for her
oh no
on foot
[Music]
oh my God no
no no no no no
God
why God too much we all are getting
right to it oh my God that was probably
the worst thing
[Music]
oh my God I was not ready for that I
really liked though that he went for it
immediately yeah you can't say he's he's
not uh determined he's not committed
yeah literally just a direct
continuation of the events wow
oh new character yeah I know him you
know him not personally he's just in
stuff he's not one of your friends
your problem was first on the scene Gary
I'm glad she's still in it I really
liked her I think she's a good actress
it's not detective Matthews
who is it where are they they're in a
different location
right oh God wait what
he's holding place by these chains
[Applause]
oh no oh no thank you jeans in a
classroom oh no no no no no no no no
oh it's the around the mouth that kills
me I can't oh my God why Jesus despite
all of the advantages
live or die try
um okay I mean for sure you're probably
gonna die right oh yeah they just showed
him like what happens the aftermath
oh please I was really hoping he didn't
show us what happened to that guy like
in in real time all he had to do
is release himself and meet you the
chains see because I'm wondering though
if he pulled his skin
it wouldn't do that though you know what
I mean
all he had to do oh God we're going back
God yeah cause I'm saying if it's
clipped to the skin that's why I'm
wondering like he died but I feel like
you pull those from the skin you um
right
okay see he did one all right
I think you're just bleeding from his
mouth dude oh my God yeah all you have
to do that guy had a point because
this is way worse this is infinitely
worse oh my God no no no no no no no no
no no
why is it
like just say he did it quick like we
don't want to see anymore this hurts me
oh my God physically hurting me right
now oh God
yeah I was like please do not show me
that it is on his ding dong because I
cannot right now Jake says game was to
get out before the ball went off
door welded shut
the guy couldn't get out if he wanted to
well that's because jigsaw is a girl now
so maybe she's like switching it up oh
could be yeah one other tag teaming
right I think he was like is he not dead
yet he's not dead yet maybe he didn't
look too good in that car from the last
time I know he looked like he was close
to his deathbed yeah
recognize my eyes closed
[Music]
why how
laughs
interesting now we're following her as
the lead and choose to support last time
yeah
oh what nope
is the tape how is this live exactly
that's weird
okay yep yep as you should
oh my God
no
where is it
oh no
how is it in the tape and in the I just
doesn't it she's already dead I like oh
she's don't like it oh okay
oh God
oh my God is that acid oh my God is that
is that freaking acid it'll melt your
face off
oh and it's in the oh that's her keto
escape and she probably has to put her
hand in there oh my God I hate this I
hate this um
[Music]
reach in and take it awful awful awful
awful
I'm sure it's not bad
it's just maybe it's just Sprite maybe
it's just Sprite it takes the skin right
down to the bone Aaron
oh my goodness nope girl it's in the rib
cage I hate this you're gonna have to do
it you have no choice
oh my God oh my God no no don't don't
tip it don't tip it it's gonna tip on
you don't burn your face oh my God girl
come on now it's just Sprite it's just
oh my God it's just
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
oh my God oh my God
hurry no oh my God can she even use that
hand can you get it to the other hand no
no this is my theater dance I hate it if
you drop that key girl I'm gonna be so
angry oh my God she got
what's happening no no yeah how does it
come out
how does it come out
she's coming in
yeah big old reveal
ah no no hate it
why what no no
no no oh holy junk that was awful she
put her hand in the acid to open it up
why does she let her go I
got more characters
Tuesday I thought you started 11. this
movie's rough y'all so he's
I was not prepared this is this is worse
immediately than the first two yeah can
we just
talk for five minutes relation no
problems what's wrong
what is it you want from me Chris
a divorce damn oh okay Lynn
pressure down to 70. oh it's a kid I
gotta crack his chest damn no we're
gonna Trail the right side I'm doing it
a Russian bear
stats are improving
she seems mad why because it wasn't
protocol
oh did she lose a kid I see a kid signed
to Mommy and we didn't see a kid up in
there maybe that's why they're going
through divorces absolutely
they're both going through grief and
isolating
he's about to get kidnapped by jigsaw or
by someone in a pig mask
I don't feel like coming no no okay
yep you called it on the hairy pig mask
I don't know why they gotta have hair no
thank you oh jigsaw is not gonna kill
himself I mean I'm gonna come to a
little puppet trying to kidnap people we
gotta have your big scary a big Persona
get your figure on get you get your Pig
on
could that go oh so many
two pigments and a lot of weapons a lot
of torture see like this kind of room
would excite me if it was for Pure
Revenge but right now we're just like
killing people out of like because he's
a psycho all right killing people you
don't even know
jig sanctuary
there she is
there's our lady jigsaw
oh he's still alive oh dang buddy oh she
kidnapped him to help him because with
his cancer yeah do you remember me
consumer
you're being tested your will is being
tested
live no what is this what are you doing
to me you're
gonna torture her to save you
are those wearing as linked to my heart
rate monitor bullets when you move out
of range an explosion will go off in
that collar your life and my life will
end simultaneously wow we have another
test subject if he completes all of his
tests and John is still breathing
and you're free to go it is bullets
shotgun
I don't think she's gonna be free to go
one thing I will say I do appreciate
appreciate about these movies is that
each one is like vastly different from
the last one they don't have that yeah
repeating the same like structure that
sequels usually have
it's a guy in a box yeah hello
and
just become your tomb
Sierra what's your angle on this
ouch
wow
how many times do I have to tell you
before you get it in your head oh
no no you're just nothing you don't
touch things in Dylan's room
stop I said he lost a daughter right he
was a son yeah
this poor girl I mean she lost her
brother she just wants to sleep with
this stuffed animal
s
okay what happened did you you saw him
and then you had your reaction like five
seconds later no like I'm with the pig
mask I just I didn't know I didn't
register no it really didn't I was like
the door's closing okay he left a gun
there I was gonna be like don't leave
the gun there with the kid and then I
registered
hairy pig mask I hairy pig mask is
freaky it's freaky freaky okay that just
the guy just left the daughter there he
left he left the dog I also with the gun
so somebody maybe the daughter will be
locked up and it's like play this game
and you can get her out but the kids
into this man I didn't mention that he
just said you'll get to meet your son's
killer who he's obsessed with that like
he wants to kill the guy
open the door open the door Jeff yeah
that the guy okay
he needs to go to the hospital and have
an operation to decompress his brain
come here I'm gonna slap her
oh
no one's going to any Hospital you're
giving him painkillers for a tumor like
this you need steroids prednisone maybe
we could try some corticoster steroids
you know like dexamethasone
don't know really you don't know
medicine he chose
not me Amanda
jealous
of our game have been made very clear
he's [__] jealous dude he chose you
not me yeah I could have saved him I
could have saved my circuit bad
[Music]
okay
I can't do vomit that's gross
oh [__] not again Amanda
[Music]
yeah you won't be big and bad I'm gonna
be a doctor but y'all freaking out when
[__] needs to go down oh my God this is
why I didn't choose you oh my God all
right
please don't throw up in The Mask I
can't do it get it together
oh my God
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
oh my gosh she's gonna put the tube down
or what what's she gonna do what's she
gonna do oh God from vomit to blood very
quick
[Music]
assistant
is that enough for you you ready to go
to the hospital now yeah
she can be like do it here right oh yeah
we do it here comment I need anesthetic
for a procedure like this
even with an anesthetic
power drill
kidnap another doctor to help her get a
whole captive staff together you guys
can do it I still need them tools though
Aaron you need them we still need that
power drill as soon as you can get you
can go to the hardware store and that's
that's like a less illegal thing that
she can do to get these needs met okay
we went from following two guys in the
saw game to a whole ensemble with
Ensemble people and now we're just
following one guy okay one guy's journey
through oh God yep
who the f is this
all right okay that has to be a tough
way to be hanging if she's live no thank
you oh this is like a freezer
we just woke up in here just like you
did
be taller
just find something to stand on come on
buddy we can do it use your tippy toes
wait did the key just not work or could
he not throw another tape you see that
another table yeah you will find a woman
in front of you chained
prevent her from running much like she
did on the day your son was hit oh
there's a girl who did it her name is
Danica Scott she was the only witness
present at the scene of your sons
untimely demise
[Music]
ah that water or acid yes it's probably
water is so cold just freezes like ice
on her I'm so sorry I'm human
Okay so the keys got to work somewhere
oh but what does that do though I mean
you're in a cold room
why is the water so torturous I don't
get that
oh my God
that was really fast that was unexpected
oh God
oh
my God what's that liquid ice you spray
it on there what the hell holy chunk
take off your sweater okay you got it
[Music]
you need to like rip his hand
oh God bro take her down she's gonna
shatter into pieces it's too [__]
light I mean buddy
oh that's so creative way to die for
sure it's rough
oh
my God no
[Laughter]
oh my God
I'm gonna have a heart attack
[Laughter]
what is that
what
oh God I thought I saw the hand and I
was like why are you oh God I'm gonna be
touching stuff I thought her hand went
you'd be surprised what tools can save a
life
[Music]
what tools can save a life well they're
flashback and a flashback as we go back
there was only one
over the device
a little soul patch
that's not the guy from the beginning in
the bed with the doctor right this guy
no it's not no okay yeah no because he
was in a totally different house never
mind yeah yeah I see you trying to make
the connections yeah I was just thinking
like where's the twist gonna come in
yeah he was like I chose her for that
reason but I'm like What's the other
right
oh jigsaw the puppet okay he fell down
who pushed the puppet also how's the uh
what I'm thinking of how's the cop in
the beginning planned all of this yeah
where is him footless footless Wahlberg
no he didn't cut it off he beat it so he
could I don't know what I'm saying
that's dangling on one nerve yeah that's
got to be gone
time to go to let go time to let go
of the sun's death because behind this
door is the killer
let me say there's like five tracks oh
I mean this guy learn your lesson buddy
that happened to like five minutes ago
I'm in here
oh a judge presiding over your case
possessions
[Music]
oh wow let the game begin please get me
out of here please
is he gonna drop it in there with him I
think he might oh my you
oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no
I ate it
oh this is disgusting
okay it's
it's not just pretend it's chocolate oh
my god maggoty pig
now
okay maybe if I just keep watching I'll
become desensitized
no I'm saying is jigsaw trying to
indoctrinate this guy to be part of the
the jigsaw team by my come to
confrontation with like life and
morality and all of this all this [__]
[Music]
teaching him to appreciate life for like
his relationship with what a life is
worth kind of like uh the girl we're
getting all these King Pigs that's what
I need to know yeah crop Department 10
out of 10. all right and I still don't
get why the the pigs are like the thing
the pig masks the dead pigs like what
yeah what's the relation here what's the
connection maybe it's because he's
saying that people are like they're like
[__] humans and pigs roll around in
their own [__]
and are like you know what I mean yeah
okay it should
let it burn let it burn gotta let it
burn yeah
they just keep coming okay
help me just oh good God this is
him to get out of there because I cannot
be looking at this screen no more with
that if it's if it's
[Music]
oh my God I can't be doing this right
now I hope you guys are enjoying this I
hope you God this makes you want to
vomit do they get worse oh it better not
to take him out of there the next cut
back too he better be out of that juice
I cannot please God the judge is alive
let me say closer than I expected yes
faster I think
are you ready to see some more things
you weren't expecting to see when you
woke up this morning yeah you mean like
her hand shaking that bad yeah girl
don't you do this all the time or his
brain and skull and my other disgusting
things girl get it together
yeah don't don't good just get in there
I'm surprised you guys are having rest
oh nope I lied I immediately regretted
that saying that I was like look at them
showing restraint not showing the actual
operation and then immediately I was
wrong
fill that syringe with alcohol from that
bowl
wait that was weird continuity his
scissors were on there but that's okay I
don't even notice that
now they're back okay
[Music]
keep your mouth closed you can hear a
lot of noise
oh God a lot of noise
keep your mouth closed why
I don't wanna know just let's do it come
on now yeah let's just get in there are
you ready for this
sawing into a prop this is not real
I put some holes in his skull
[Music]
a little better that's wild
I thought that was gonna be it okay
I'm remembering now
[Music]
okay he's he's okay what in the
flashback is this yeah well when you
surround your brain I'm sure you get a
lot
um
yep that's a piece of your school
what is this
oh God there's a film between the brain
and the skull I never knew that oh boy
your fingers
yeah right
[Music]
you did the thing you're supposed to do
why it's happening still in his memory
who's this girl
oh God that's too low he's dead you're
gonna blow up now lady
[Music]
he's stuck in his afterlife after Alive
come back to the bright white light come
on now
[Music]
or did she die too is that what also
brought you over the edge
she's waiting
[Music]
for me
that was the one that was on accident
jealous again yeah I mean she's a little
captive bird her brain is all sorts of
messed up
I'm gonna kill her now what was in that
is pictures right you're about to do
drugs what is this no it looks like that
looks like I think she's like what's in
there oh okay oh because she is it
because she's a
is that chlorophyll there is no turning
back do you want to
Hunters yes
[Music]
no she's not gonna do it okay
it was in that bottle whoa
oh my God who's that uh
just killed the guy in his name
I guess that's what she had to do that
was in the file wait did you kill the
guy from the first movie the
photographer guy oh
she's about to drive
[Music]
that's a big one girl don't don't oh
she's hiding it from him because he was
like don't be doing that no more
[Music]
oh
and then she got it
with him since the first one
oh she just knocked him out
okay this is the whole setup for one
yeah oh she's been involved because
remember she was in the very very
beginning and then she survived and then
we cut to them yeah so he turned her
like right away and now okay oh wow
she's with him from the beginning okay
all right all right we're following this
timeline okay I see I see how are there
ten of these
a lot of ways to kill people yeah
clearly
my God this [__] is not
surviving for like 10 movies man
oh I'm just gonna give him a good sniff
you're only gonna make it worse
ah
yeah
chill chick chill he's trying to save
him for you
oh damn girl why you keep she been
tripping the whole time
oh damn oh she's cutting her hand right
now I think also I'm like doctor don't
keep offending the woman who can
literally is like so crazy she's about
to blow your brains out like right she
calls her a freak As She's Walking Away
because we just locked the the gate on
him after the first movie so we don't
know what happened to him
okay why would you why he's already
gonna die was that necessary that's very
much not necessary to do this right now
oh
wow jeez
okay okay
I'm gonna guess he didn't tell you to do
that so you just
did it yeah
oh this guy we're still yeah we're still
helping him that's right we didn't cut
back to remember I said it better be a
fresh cut back where there's no more Pig
juice you're so happy for it your
clothes look strangely clean yeah very
clean as to be expected good Lord very
clean did they go through the washer
foreign
don't bring his daughter into this no
sentence I gave
I gave 500 years not even death nothing
you're paying me
to the puzzle you hit his wife into this
another one okay is this the guy is this
the killer
this is the guy the way the way he's
looking at him all right let's play the
tape so we can get the juice here
young a man whose life also changed the
day your son died
[Applause]
it was your chance to make him pay I
call it the rack
God
I wonder how far the arm can twist this
device is going to start twisting oh no
at the back of the box is a key it's
time to the trigger of a shotgun are you
willing have mercy to take a bullet oh
the doctor's gonna itself or the the
judge
just standing there you're accomplished
you all need to find some scissors and
cut that key off
three years
[Music]
oh okay [__]
who got higher than the shotgun stood on
something so when you grabbed it it
would go in between your legs this is
where my brain is at right now like
would that no I would still probably get
your hand oh yeah oh my God this is just
I can't oh he's dead he is dead he won't
be fast enough
the shotgun's gonna go off yes that was
absolutely that oh my God this is all
this tension
Jesus
I mean his limbs are already off like
just what are we doing here oh my God
this is awful this is the worst
damn
yep see you later all right
[Music]
nope
he's already dead I mean you're so late
to the game this guy you waited way too
long every time he goes to get the key
they're dead they're already dead buddy
oh God it's gonna snap his neck oh my
god do something with the key guys what
are you doing where is the key
[Music]
yeah that's a dead guy that's a dead
that's a dead brother right there okay
matrimony is always fascinated me wires
on their backs until rooms
my marriage has survived more suffering
than someone like you could ever grasp
you haven't seen anything yet
what you did say there's one reason
there's one reason why I chose her
what's the other
what
Amanda's not gonna like hearing that
you're making her jealous he wants my
man I know it
was trying to steal him from me he's
completed the third test
congratulations Lynn you're free to go
and do her call
Amanda Lynn is more important unlock her
car and let her go ours
yo dude chill you promised I promise you
[__] Amanda you know
your life
Iran why at least I have a family
other test subjects is that how you
thought about them I'll tell you how I
felt about Eric Matthews
I don't even know how he's still
dragging it there's no way Eric Matthews
nothing from your test
[Music]
oh
okay why are you attacking her
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
remember you saw her come up in the
bathtub right didn't even know that it
was like or she came into the room right
I think so I don't remember
oh where's my son where is he junking
[__]
oh right because he you remember
arresting her right
here
I didn't even see that did not want to
see that
yeah she's that doesn't make sense I
don't know why he would why would he say
that
nobody is reborn and I'm just a pawn in
your stupid games
all right
from the door Jeff
what do you want
what time's running out
think about everything that you've done
he's here now let's think about tomorrow
oh
it is him
oh yeah I knew I I had okay
it was him oh man you're dumb your will
is being tested
[Music]
yeah okay
God he dies and now the lady blows up if
he died her collar would explode if she
that's what I mean she she would blow
like your wife's fate is in my hands I
can have an ambulance here right four
minutes
be my protege he's a host of vicious
implements
to take your Vengeance to indulge your
Obsession Obsession
I forgive you
yeah oh God yep nope nope
oh
yep here we go okay that's death hello
Jeff I told you that you could kill me
I am the only
one
where your daughter is
another one how I mean the guy's dead
how do we how do we how do we
[Music]
oh wow
wow wow wow wow
ah huh that was uh that was a lot wow
okay
yeah I mean oh my God okay so like
holy crap holy [__] that was from the
beginning way more than one and two oh
yeah way more and also I'm like how is
he that means that
jigsaw knew prior that Jeff was gonna
fail meaning he already has a game set
up but how right if he's dead right
unless we shows up on four or something
that like he taped his neck and he saved
him I don't think he'd be able to do
that this man is playing three
dimensions
oh man he's still living he's got a game
all set up for Jeff
or maybe we just dude this was a great
ride but it was nasty and it was intense
yeah a lot of the times I was like
please no this is the grossest one of
the three Fishers so gross
so gross wow I I will say that it's it's
very different from other horror movies
that I've seen in the in the sense that
there doesn't have a lot of scares per
se it's mostly just like gross and
horrific images right but psychological
psychological stuff but it tries to have
something of a message about revenge and
morality and the choices that we make
and I think a lot of them have had that
or the ones we've had have had that kind
of consistent thing going
but yeah it's uh this one was wild I
will say that I
even though we didn't outright like say
it kind of how we're talking about in
the first one I did see the twist of him
being the husband coming
pretty much like for most of it because
right because remember me in the
beginning I'm like is that that guy but
then it was it wasn't him it wasn't it
was that she was she was cheating on him
right right but then I'm like but then
why did that guy say I want a divorce
doesn't make sense because then I'm like
but if that's her Hut that's what that's
a little confusing to me but yeah but I
maybe he wanted a divorce from his wife
so he can finally be with her right
right I mean
I think that's us putting the pieces
together but I think it was confusing
for confusing we were trying to link it
yeah okay it was to take off off the US
off of the trail but yeah I still felt
that like okay this there's something of
a connection here because she lost a
daughter he had oh he she lost a kid he
happened to have lost a kid what are the
odds that these two are not connected
because we've known at least in the
first two there's some major twists at
the end this has like become a staple of
this franchise at this point so I think
because we're aware of that we're
looking for it so I think that I was
looking for that connection
for like most of it and by the time that
the actual twist happened I wasn't my
mind wasn't blown like it was at the end
of the first and second movie right
right were you were you Blown Away by
that twist or
I mean the twist of him
showing what's her nuts jigsaw lady
um Mrs jigsaw Amanda
um The Twist of it being a test for her
I did not see coming which I did enjoy
that at the end of like this was all set
up
uh just for her to like test her limits
um
yeah and because you really had to put
all those pieces together to get the
doctor saying like she's worth it to you
more than you know and then him I guess
knowing that like a man is gonna shoot
that girl and he he has to capture
Jeff's daughter and put her away because
the test all loops around to there at
the end ah I don't know I will tell you
one thing Jeff got way too late to the
Keys way too late it's literally like
why did he take so much time he took too
much time thinking about it you heard
the tape go for the key but meanwhile he
was like I'll look at him and maybe I
like him like who are you and then
they're like then they're like crying in
pain we learned it with the first woman
and then he goes to get the key and he
doesn't even look what what's who's
standing back there I mean Jeff Jeff I
had some struggles in there I got mad at
him also when one door you guys know I
talk about this every time I do not like
when people leave a weapon behind and it
also really bugged me that Jeff saw the
door close behind him in the first door
I'm like take a thing and shove it
behind come on now but then I guess was
the door did the door ever lock I kind
of looked like it locked it was very
nice so I think even he did put
something in it would like crush it it
would crush it okay that would make me
feel better I would still I would still
really like it if a character put a
thing there and then it crushed it at
least you tried at least you tried do
something smart yeah sometimes I just
get so irritated that they don't do
certain things but the I mean I did have
a lot of fun watching this but it was
nasty
gross like
yeah yeah it was super gross I will say
I said it during as we were watching it
but something I really did appreciate
appreciate about the movie was the fact
that each one is very different from the
last one and they're all these weirdly
connected movies even though there's
individual stories that were taking
place that on the surface don't seem
connected but through jigsaw and through
the games that they're playing they have
like this through line and I like that
it's interesting because I've never seen
I don't I don't watch a ton of horror
but I've never seen
um a franchise where the antagonist or
the person who's doing the the murders
or the killings or whatnot or become a
prominent main character in the stories
because the first one yeah he would like
they kind of teased him and then you
reveal that he was the Dead Guy the
whole time the second one it was like uh
almost like a Hannibal lecture kind of
thing like they're they're both sitting
in the room so he was a character in
that second one but I think it being the
most prominent of like oh we're spending
a majority of this story with Amanda
with Jigsaw and with this doctor and
that that took more screen time than the
game with the husband did yeah and I was
like okay very interesting very
interesting that this is the route we're
going with it my thing is like okay he's
dead she's dead who's gonna continue
this game or is it just like a series of
of games that he's planted for like
because it was like right multiple
because like to not hear here's the
thing why I keep thinking like how do
they kill them off because to not hear
his voice narrating of like Jeff your
game like it's gonna be weird to hear
another voice uh and maybe that's why
they made him more prominent because
he's a great actor and maybe I don't
know they were just like we need to show
jigsaw guy more but it is going to be
weird to not hear his voice if they have
to if they killed him and then maybe he
sets up one more game but like there's
so many of these there's no way he's
like he's dead and he's set up like
eight more games so there has to be
another like narrator or jigsaw person
obviously who's it gonna be I don't know
will I be mad about the voice in the
background for a hot second because I've
gotten used to this guy talking
uh he's a staple he's our he's a staple
saw guy he's he's there for Comfort like
okay yeah you're like okay I get it
yeah he's going to take us through it
he's going to be the voice behind the
tapes of like you mess this up that was
a bad impression I tried though would
you like to play a game ah that was
pretty good thank you I mean guys I
don't have a lot of thoughts except that
I had I did have a lot of fun but like
gross like I want it to be a little less
gross like please get out of the pig
juice way sooner than we were in it also
the foot twists at the top
y'all I mean
it's it this one was intense I really
liked it I'm gonna rate it eight out of
ten the twists at the end with Amanda I
didn't see coming
um yeah I in I enjoyed that I mean what
do you how much what a what do you think
what's your rating what's your
I I liked it uh I thought it was grosser
than the other two I didn't like the
twist as much as the first two because
the other two blew my mind like I kind
of like
put pieces together during the first one
with the second one caught me way off
guard and this third one I think the
twist was cool and I liked how it
related to the characters it was more
the second one was was character based
as well but I think the fact that it
dealt more with the people that were the
perpetrators of this whole game yeah and
it being a a game about her I thought
was was clever
um but yeah I will say I I enjoyed it
I'm still having a great time with these
movies uh I will say I will give this
one like a seven seven out of seven and
a half I'm down with that ten yeah yeah
I like it uh any last thoughts you got
before we say sayonara
oh this is gross uh me and Greg watched
Slither and this is probably like five
times grosser than that so
I uh I don't know what's gonna happen
next but um yeah these movies have been
a ride so far yeah they have been a lot
of fun this was super gnarly we love you
guys don't forget to leave a like leave
a comment tell us what other scary
movies we should watch and just tell us
that we look cool and that you like our
t-shirts and you know the good stuff all
the good stuff we didn't plan this by
the way we just happened
and we were like hey
hey
and that's it we love you and we'll see
you on the next one bye